good evening everyone I think we should
make a start it's 5:30 welcome to
tonight's extraordinary to the East area
planning committee my name is Danny
Kendall have each errand tonight's
meeting in accordance with some of the
procedures are set out in the front page
of your over the agenda this of course
is an unusual meeting actually I think
we should start by saying that this
first meeting of tonight which is one
agenda we have two summations is not to
decide or look at a planning application
or any sort it's in relation to an
application is it can having it's in
relation to a planning application from
last August so that probably will come
up at some point but I think the most
important thing I want to say is really
this is not to read aside or re-examine
that planning decision that is a
separate application of what we're
looking at today and looking at to write
is a very different decision a very
different case all together so I will
make that very clear at the outset of
meeting should we just introduce people
as well to make sure as usual is divorce
committee services there are chambers on
my right who will be our legal
representative here tonight as well
we're also joined by Phil Grafton who
will be speaking well next I think so
forth if I could hand over to you how is
that okay Thank You chairman Pollan
sorry apologies for absence we've got
thank you very much and just of course I
should say disclosures of interest
before I move on to that any at all yes
council the interested party of the
neighboring interested party back in oh
four I'm perfectly happy to take a
neutral stand on this and view it but I
didn't sit in the last committee meeting
of course thank you okay we've got that
noted then less that's fine right if
they know other disclosures of interests
apologies Phil over to you thank you
Thank You chairman and what I'd like to
do with your permission is just to
briefly skirt through the reports so you
sort of familiar with what would here
for tonight to then secondly make just a
few general points about the difference
that councilor Kendall just mentioned
between a revocation request and an
ordinary planning application and then
we goes into the meat of it which are
really around the process for today's
meeting and there will be a number of
points that we need to settle before we
can move into discussing the whole
matter so just to start off this this
matter concerns a request for revocation
of a planning consent that was granted
last August by your committee for White
House Farm Aid Lakota Road Italy coat
there was a request at that time for a
planning application and also a listed
building consent the application is you
can see from point one point two in my
report was for demolition of certain
block work extensions an open frontier
car shed and the conversion of some
agricultural buildings to convert into
three dwellings to include the erection
of a new three bay carport it was
actually and it is significant a
resubmission of two previous
applications there had been a previous
inspectors Appeal decision going back to
November 2016 when the appeal was
dismissed and in essence there were some
key concerns raised by the inspector in
his decision about the heritage asset
and the inspector had concluded at that
time that the benefits of the dis the
proposal will not consider the
that time to outweigh the less than
substantial harm identified to the
Heritage assets you'll find a full copy
of the inspectors Appeal decision at
appendix want to the report during that
committee hearing objection was raised
by and this is a correction in my report
it occurred parish meeting not Council
there were also a number of letters
objections from 17 in fact concerning
the impact of the development the office
of recommendation however was to grant
the application and the officers report
is also attached to my report at
appendix to Castle O'Donnell who has
subsequently made the request for
revocation had stood down from the
meeting and acted in her role as ward
member the eventual outcome after a site
visit was that the committee had voted
to grant the applications by four votes
to one and the notice of decision was
then issued and then of course a period
of time will pass in which there is the
opportunity for a judicial review but
for one reason or another the council
didn't receive any notice of challenge
within that period or indeed since then
however on the 28th of November last
year the head of Housing and Planning
received a letter from the nearby
residence which is also in your PAC
requesting the revocation of the
planning permission the grounds for that
were concerned with the advice that the
Planning Manager had given to the
Planning ace committee back in August
and claiming in essence that the advice
given to the committee was misleading
the head of planning and and housing
decided to commission some legal advice
at that time and the advice is also in
your pack the conclusion as I've put in
paragraph one point thirteen is that
whilst the officer had misled to some
extent the committee it was not what she
considered to be seriously misleading
and therefore she did not think that it
was necessary to be revisited by the
committee the head of Housing and
Planning then provided a copy of that
report to the residents and more
recently a copy was provided to cancer
O'Donnell as well we now bring it
forward to March of this year when
counsel O'Donnell I have to say that the
residents request for revocation had
then been sorted out by for council if
you remember on the 26th of February
where we made some changes to the
Constitution and at that point what we
agreed was that where we had requests
the revocation from members of the
public the head of paid service would
make a decision in consultation with the
chair of the Planning Committee and and
the portfolio holder as to whether to
put it on the agenda but in the case of
a request from the local ward member or
a member of the council there was no
choice it is that request that came from
councillor O'Donnell at the beginning of
March which has led to this meeting
today and in effect what council
O'Donnell has done is to adopt the
grounds of complaint that was set out by
the residents back in November of last
year in preparation for this meeting
I have contacted the developer the
developers agent as well to notify them
that this request has been made to
advertise the fact that
this meeting is taken today and you will
see in your pack a letter from the
developer solicitor making certain
representations and indeed we have
counsel for the developer here today mr.
Robert Walton who's sitting somewhere
behind me councillor Donald you'll note
is is not here today I had first given
her notice of this meeting a month ago
but late last week she advised the head
of paid service that she couldn't be
here today and then I think it was
yesterday or the day before advised that
she would like to have councilor kettle
to act in her stead just to run through
well perhaps we shouldn't be running
through right now the decisions you have
to make today except to say a couple of
things about the difference between this
situation and an ordinary planning
application so a request for a
revocation is a separate and totally
different process from the process for
dealing with a planning application with
a planning application as you know the
decision-making process is regulated
right from the beginning to the end of
the process in terms of consultation
requirements timescales
the hearing process and by law the local
planning authority must make a decision
in contrast to that for forum for a
revocation of a planning permission we
start with section 97 of the Turner
Country Planning Act which simply states
that a local authority may revoke a
consent if it is expedient to do so
there's no defined legal process leading
up to the decision no requirement for
requests to be made and no requirement
for any decision to be made on a require
as your chairman pointed out earlier the
role of the committee is not to rerun
the planning application and the local
planning authority is quite entitled to
stand by its decision so those are the
major differences I did mention earlier
that there are some procedural points
that we need to get through there are
five procedural points and if you can
stay with me for a bit I need to just
describe what those five points are well
they all go back to the first
recommendation in the report on page one
you'll see that the first recommendation
is that the committee determines the
procedure for hearing the request today
taking into account the advice at
paragraph one point eighteen of my
report so if you quickly turn to
paragraph one point eighteen on page
four you'll see that I have suggested a
process for hearing the request today
with ten stages in it Phil would you
mind if I come in here is before you go
in to describe describing the rest of
the process the only thing I think at
this point and now that Phil's explained
the reason for the meeting the reason
we're all here today is to set out what
I think we should be doing as well for
the rest of the meeting I really think
that for a number of reasons the things
that we should really be addressing
today are the process that we're going
to follow for this meeting rather than
going into anything beyond that today I
think that because it's such an
important issue I would rather and
timing is not necessarily an easy thing
given we've got a planning meeting which
is scheduled to come up after this as
well I would like to take the time
tonight to discuss and decide the
process as Phil said and also to give
the council Road Anwar chance to be here
for the full meeting when it eventually
happens but that's where I would like to
go with today's meeting I just want to
make sure make sure the committee are
aware of what I thought at this point as
well is that all right
so Phil would you like to start on the
process and thank you so far these five
procedural points point one
ruling by the committee really the
process that I set out in 1.18 of course
assumes that the requestor councillor
O'Donnell is here and presents her
request but she isn't here counselor
Christopher kettle is within the room as
I say counselor O'Donnell was notified
some time ago that there was a meeting
today the question for the committee I
would suggest is whether they allow
councilor kettle to stand in her absence
and if the answer is yes are there any
limitations that they wish to place on
the extent of his involvement in this
matter and and the other question would
be what wait does the committee feel
should be placed on his comments so
that's the first procedural point the
second procedural point is just to note
that one of the documents which is on
blue paper in appendix five and we're
talking about the legal advice that
starts at page 57 and ends at page 63
since the publication of the report I
have taken the decision to place that
document on white paper and of course
what that means is that rather being an
exempt part of the report it is now in
the public domain I better just explain
that originally the view taken was that
that document was integral to the other
documents in that appendix which
themselves
would I'm suggesting be retained on blue
paper simply because the but the point
being that the the reason I've placed it
onto white paper is because a request
came from the developers solicitor
for the document and at that point I
decided to detach it from the blue paper
so it's just to for you to understand
that that that now is on white paper
committee services have a copy of that
legal advice and we'll hand it round in
a moment if you could do that in a
second point number three or you go to
point number three counselor brain has a
question is that okay
obviously the preference would be for
cancer O'Donnell to be here I don't know
the reason why she's not here
probably you do and if that's the case
she's not here but she isn't this
cleanser Castle gonna read the notes or
is it his own representation well that
would be the first point I'm sorry and
we're jumping in all over the five point
shoe on talk about the first one in
terms of counselor kettles role because
it very clearly my view is that because
this is sentence come from counselor
O'Donnell and it is a very very serious
matter my view is that it's so says we
should give her the opportunity to be
here to make her points and we're very
grateful to counselor kettle for being
here and you know Kelly stepping in but
it's really important I think that
counselor Don will be given that
opportunity so in terms of point one I
think and maybe I asked you advice and
what you think of this feel just point
one falling away if we make the decision
that we defer the meeting or adjourn the
meeting until a day later date you have
a legal advisor next to you but I say
what what what I feel that that really
we we need to sort out the procedure in
order then to run it and I would have
said it was equitable for counselor
O'Donnell who has been corresponding
throughout until today to have the
opportunity to come here
okay and with that yeah Ross in terms of
that I have what's your view does that
make sense as well to give pick outs
with all the opportunity to be here yeah
I mean it's four members I mean really
what we're saying is should councillor
O'Donnell be able to appoint a
substitute for this or would you prefer
that has the requester she makes the
case ourselves it's and that's that's
part of the process that needs to be
decided today right
yes counselor Cargill slightly contrary
view obviously if councillor Donnell has
asked councilor kettle to present for
her she must be feel comfortable with
that therefore why can't he do that fair
point
did anybody so you perhaps Mills you
were indicating you wanted to come in
and counsel truck yeah thanks mr.
chairman yeah it's difficult one
I don't feel just like kicking the can
down the road but I don't know
councillor Donald to be here thank you
thank you my only concern is that
obviously you can't slow down all is the
expert on this issue since today I did
this and lives must have lived and
breathed the case to bring a sort and
not not to criticize counselor kettle
I'm not sure whether he will of the
in-depth knowledge and the ability to
ask questions are not scripted to answer
that so it's that's that's the thing I
would like to write tries fair point and
agree with my colleagues that we need
counselor Donnell here as counselor bond
said last time we had counselor kettle
he wasn't able to answer questions
because he wasn't in his ward and I
think that it unless he is here we
should perhaps of course the I mean of
course the recent changes I should
probably explain the recent changes have
allowed for in future a substitute
counsel would be able to answer
questions that's fine I think probably
it's a slightly different point because
that's
normal state of affairs while you were
doing you know the usual planning
applications and I think it's fair this
is a very very different situation and I
think because it's so different I think
it's important we would if possible have
councillor Donnell here so it capsule
abarnes were you indicating he was told
he couldn't it is capsule Milt thank you
this is an awesome massive decision I
mean it's a massive issue I think we've
gotta get it right and I think that
penny and O'Donnell must be here right I
think only reason for us to vote all
that just yet we probably will come to
that in a second but when I think this
is gonna be it
it's like I see you're indicating but
I've got to say at this point this isn't
this is a meeting amongst the committee
not for members from the public or any
other members of the council I so I'm
gonna ask that I'm afraid I won't let
you take part at this part of the
conversation I'm sorry so we stay very
strictly to the committee from there and
that's what we're discussing as weird as
it sounds about whether we can bring you
in at the at a later time yes that's the
feeling within the council and it is
going to take some time to iron out I
think we need time to get to get to
grips with it and perhaps bring it back
when we got no other planning issues on
that day I think I agree completely with
that right okay felt back to where you
work so we've gone off of a bit of a
tangent I think we should draw back to
point number launch you've made which is
I suppose if a if we've made it clear
that we would like our adult can speak
at this next meeting if that's where
we're going with this I suppose we still
need to iron out whether or not we
rather if she was in that situation
still unable to attend whether or not we
would permit councilor kettle to speak
on her behalf then and what role he
would have my correct okay
so back to the point if councillor
Donald's not able to attend and I know
that's our preference that she does come
but if for whatever reason she's delayed
or can't make it again and she again
requests councillor kettles presence how
do we feel about allowing council
council kettled to speak on her behalf
and to even take questions for her and
what wait should that take cats the
brain then I come back sorry I did ask
if we knew the reason why cancer Donal
wasn't here and if he's prepared
statement was with Chris kettle or not
do we have a reason catalyst in terms of
it just apologies no my understanding is
that she has work commitments okay so
perhaps on that point we come back to
what counsel fielding was saying we have
it on a different day about sort of more
convenient our maybe the you know the
standard six o'clock start instead yes
Miss Jamaica can we insist the counter
on beginner next time I don't think yes
I was just going to comment I think if
councillor a Donna wants to appoint a
substitute and she's happy to do that
then I don't think you can prevent that
the question is how much weight do you
put on the substitutes comments and do
you put as much weight on those comments
as if she were here herself so I think
it would be difficult to prevent her
appointing a substitute but but then it
goes to a question of weight counselor
it's the committee's preference that
counts the O'Donnell attended in person
and again it's now it's light on the
character or the ability accounts the
kettle but is our committees preference
that she attend and it would be better
if she was that I think well we can
really make that request I think
currently when we if we reschedule I
think that's a perfectly reasonable
request to make back to the point which
is I think it makes a fair point we
can't insist the counselor Donald come
we can request and that'd be great if
she could be here so back to the issue
council kettle
my feeling is that he should we journey
because anybody else have any ideas at
this point anything else I want to raise
in terms of what role he would have cuz
obviously kept films mitt laid out the
case she's we need to decide what
accounts the cattle could do as a
substitute yes Thank You chairman mining
concern would be if we say as an example
not putting words into anyone's mouths
that if cows were Donnell is unable to
come the next time and countlessly
kettle substitutes what's the difference
from doing it now it's a fair point and
I get that but I think I would like to
extend that opportunity and I also and I
think the fielding said it's going to
take a lot longer than we'd like I think
it's not going to be a quick meeting and
I think given that we do have we will
have people waiting shortly in about 25
minutes from now I don't think it would
be fair to make them way to push the
other meeting back that far so I kept
the brain compress young Catholic up
young so my concern is that one of the
reasons why we're here is that there was
concern about the factual evidence of
the information and we need to make sure
we've got the turtle information
accurate information no ambiguity so
therefore if we're going to do it I
would prefer that we got it right we
took our time it wasn't rushed and then
we can't be accused of not taking the
matter seriously so if we've got other
you know we've got you know who said
before counts low done all as obviously
lived and breathed this case and she's
the expert and that is my preference
yeah others might disagree but that's
the way after that moment so it's hard
to catch when did you want to make we
can't get it right and that we didn't
make sure that she could look at all the
people of God yes look at the waste of
time in offices time etc I mean I think
we've stuck with a green recommendations
one and
well let's go through these then I think
so we need to come back on I know what
traipsing all over the points here right
skaters roll we need to decide should be
situational eyes though that counts low
dollar Carnegie to get our we contend
for gaps the capital to speak on their
behalf and that's the nub of the issue
that we need to get to right now making
decisions of committee counsel filling I
have no objection to cattle counselor
kettle I'm talking if O'Donnell can't
make it okay well I'm equally I think we
have to make that allowance maybe the
case it might be likely that make that
case and only we need to say well he can
take questions as well in that
particular yes could we ask the
committee to agree that aspect in terms
of that point or okay if there's five
discrete points we start with sorry
counts cable we start with the below
macaque the counselor kettle point which
we started okay right and how do you
feel about our accounts the cattle if in
that situation to take questions on
behalf of counselor O'Donnell at the
next time yet yes right and Phil correct
me we decide the amount of weight that
that would have sorry how severely have
it is an extraordinary planning each
meeting because we do need the time it
is a first and I think there's going to
be a lot of chewing and fraying with
legals it's event hangs together it's a
very fair point and yes I think that
that's almost goes without saying now at
this point yes Kel scales excellent
counselor mmm-hmm and in would do my job
and so he's penny and she must have
baby's going to be here because super
person but how can Kelso kettle our
answer questions I mean he's not in a
penny air and he's not
- is that gonna be very very difficult
I think councils that would come down to
the amount of white yeah you give to
these representations so I think as
committee we get into point we're not
opposed for second but we got we're
accepting that somebody can substitute
for they can take questions would we say
it shouldn't really be prescriptive
about for you okay right so we've got a
decision I think it will need to be
proposed and seconded that in this
situation the councilor kettle could
speak on behalf of cows O'Donnell and
could take questions and I have a
proposal yes yes thank you very much and
do I have a second council cramp
all those in favor of that decision then
okay all right so we could point to I
don't need this proposing a second thing
which is the just for noting this was
about the legal advice which has moved
from the blue exempt paper into the
white paper
point number three of course as you know
the reason that these are on blue paper
is because I as report author have
decided they should be but of course the
fact is that today it's up to the
committee to decide whether they should
remain on blue paper or not
what I'm going to suggest to you is that
they do remain on blue paper orbit
except for the legal advice and that at
any point when anyone wants to talk
about any of those documents which are
exempt that a resolution is passed by
the committee to exclude the press and
public remembering that the reason that
I've put them on blue paper is because
they contain personal information
relating to certain officers well do we
need to discuss that committee
yes council fielding if we
have an extraordinary meeting could we
have the blue pages first before we
bring the public in without the way
around it these are the blue pages that
we're referring to that we have here
before you already you already have them
yeah and if that's the case then the
public would have to be excluded at that
point but I correct yes
that's the box my name is on the blue
papers I think I can happy I have prose
I agree with what Phil said there I
think that makes perfect sense that it
remains on blue paper because of the
personal nature of those things that
makes sense to me that we would have to
exclude people if we go on to that area
I'm a pros do I have a seconder for that
council Mills we vote on that we all
content with that all those in favor
please sure everyone right arising from
your decision at point three what is the
position of can sell for the developer
because the situation is at the moment
that he does not have any of those
documents on blue paper and may wish to
address you I don't know around whether
she he should have access to those
papers
kasa bones think he'll spread the only
behind there is a bit that I know but as
far as I'm concerned if we've got ever
fair discussion I think you should be
allowed to see them what we've seen yes
counselor brain you indicated first yes
I think probably in the interest of
fairness in the interest of fairness for
the applicants representatives to see
the totality of the papers is the best
course well I think we've got a clear
steer there we have uh proposed that
will you do that please
councillor Mills send about Kurt Chicago
and all those in favor then please thank
you where are we point five lastly so we
know or at least are at my understanding
is that the requester counselor
O'Donnell will be putting forward an
alternative suggested process that for
the hearing from the one that I have
proposed at paragraph one point eighteen
of my report at some point perhaps not
today I don't know
the committee will need to decide what
procedure to adopt if I can just take
you back to one point eighteen you can
see there's a sort of ten step process
there if I can say that points one to
seven there's then a pause because the
first decision that you need to make at
that point is whether you want to debate
the issue or not if you do not wish to
debate it then that's the end of the
matter
if you do wish to debate it then you go
on to look at point nine which is
whether you're minded to revoke the
planning consent and then assuming you
do then the committee meeting
is adjourned because you will need to
take advice from the cabinet with regard
to the financial consequences on the
public purse of making the revocation
order and the statutory compensation
that would be necessary but the main
point that I'm making is that that
process might be subject perhaps next
time we come here to an alternative
process that might be put forward by
councillor O'Donnell okay I said that my
view on this to start with
I intend via this process been started
by councilor O'Donnell's request she is
requesting that we or we look at
revoking a planning application we're
planning approval I should say that's a
fair point
she's made her request to revoke I then
take the view that actually it's for
this committee to make the decision on
what the process is and I don't think
it's for this committee to have to be
have to be given various options by
there are certain people on the process
I think it's for us to decide
and if we're content with what's in
front of us here I think that's for us
to decide now and I'll put my cards on
the table I am happy with this process
as proposed in the report Council it
back again just a clarification please
so on item 5 we said the planning a
applicant agent owner tenant of
submissions five minutes first is that
five minutes each
no that's five minutes in total I the
the important point would be to balance
the the duration at point three and the
duration of 0.5 fair enough okay that's
that's the principle and the other one
would be at that point would the
applicants legal representation yes in
other words that if the planning
applicant wanted counsel for example to
deal with 0.5 then that would be
permissible right and if you feel that
those time limits are too short or too
long okay again I've got to point out
this is strictly right now for committee
to be discussing it can't open it up to
members of the public because otherwise
I think we'll the otherwise I think we
will lose control of where we're going
with this I would like the meeting to
stay focused at this point very much on
the process and that's what we're going
to be doing and I'm hopefully committee
sort of support me in there
yes council fielding as well as Phil has
put out his process could we have as
clearly marked out
O'Donnell's alternative so that we can
see it against the two together I don't
think if we've got a concern with this
process I think we can raise that now
but I again if we start ripping in a
menu of different options we will be
here for a very long time just solely
deciding a process of a meeting and
that's not really what we're here for
I don't think so the thing we do need to
discuss is whether anything 5 minutes is
about right or more it would be a bit
would be appropriate but I think it
would be nice to give people if I'll be
honest I think 5 is a little bit short
I'd be happy to extend it to 10 because
I get an it is an it is detailed I think
10 minutes each will be more appropriate
and of course we will be able to
question people as well as usual but I
think give them
the complexity of what we're discussing
here five minutes in it short so what do
we think on that well I would like to
spear a committee decision really
chairman we've done it before extended
speaking right
I just want to make sure we addressed
this dress addresses with the committee
capsicum then Kasimir sorry you've got
one small minor point that obviously
it's very new to us and with we fast for
clarification on several issues already
tonight and I'm just wondering that
process where there we have something
built in four points of clarification
Christmas we might be I'm just this is
fair we've got questions slot we've got
a question yes questions of the
requester questions of the applicant do
you say a points of clarification the
way that we would ask maybe the pilot or
sometimes perhaps we could put that in
in between six and seven points of
clarification
just sorry to interject that it's a good
point but we who would we ask the
questions of and would we bring back
people who have been refreshed and
already it's an interesting point but
I'm sorry I apologize and we have
obviously an opportunity to question the
people who else would we ask for
questions of clarification of that's my
point
I mean that's that's have legal rights
to right well you can ask questions of
your legal adviser any time you've got
here committee questions for the officer
presenting the report that's built into
the proposed process I suggest that's
sufficient I think I think that's how do
you make a good point I think it's going
to be an unusual meeting and I think
we'll be able to be reasonably flexible
with questions we ask I think that's
fine we can do that right calibrate
think it's all we actually need to do is
egg is a green number one number two
will be deliver to start of the next
meeting if that's what we're going to do
now before we do hold on
are we all content with the processes
set out here with the additional changes
of ten minutes with speaking rights well
I will propose that second Thank You
councillor Mills if we were all in favor
of that please sure perfect I think then
lovely so we've agreed the process I
think then I'm happy to produce that we
now adjourn this meeting until a date
that will be set where other people can
attend as well
it'll be hopefully at a six o'clock
start I think absolutely that's already
been agreed that's my proposal I have a
second to please it's the brain all
those in favor of a journey thank you
very much
committee that has adjourned until we
can come back and address this again
thank you very much everyone go about
two minutes till the next meeting relax
enjoy yourselves